نعم، أنت تحب الابتسام، لقد كان
يضحك كثيرًا عندما ترى الطفل أوين
اليوم، من الصعب تصديق أنه جاء
خلال دقيقة واحدة من عدم وجوده هنا
بمجرد عدم تمكنهم من العثور على نبضات القلب،
ففكرت نوعًا ما أنه
قد يكون هناك شيء ما  حدث خطأ في شهر فبراير،
علمت ستيفاني والدة أوين أن شيئًا ما ليس صحيحًا،
فدخلت في المخاض في مستشفى ميرسي
بسبب آلام في الصدر واكتشف الأطباء أن
إمدادات الدم لطفلها قد انقطعت،
وسرعان ما استعدوا لعملية
ولادة طارئة تعطلت قليلاً أعتقد أنني
سمعتهم  اتصل للحصول على الرمز الأزرق
لحديثي الولادة وما كان يمر
بي أثناء حدوث ذلك هو أن
طفلي سيموت
وسألته وقلت هل سيكون على
ما يرام وهم كما لو أننا لا نستطيع إخبارك
متى ولد أوين  وبعد وقت قصير
لم يكن يتنفس ولم يكن لديه نبض
لمدة 16 دقيقة طويلة، وعمل الفريق الطبي
بشكل محموم لمحاولة إنقاذ
حياته، كنت أقترب جدًا من الوقت
الذي ربما قلنا فيه أن هذا لا يمكن
النجاة منه.  وكنا قد توقفنا عن
محاولة الإنعاش، لقد كان
يقترب حقًا من تلك الفترة الزمنية ولكن بعد ذلك
حصلوا على نبض مهما كان خافتًا ثم
أخذ أوين نفسًا لأول مرة في
حياته ليعيش طفل حديث الولادة 16
دقيقة بدون نبض قلب ولا
يوجد أكسجين.  من النادر البقاء على قيد الحياة دون أي آثار طويلة المدى،
وهو الأمر الذي لم يُسمع به من قبل الكثير من
الممرضات الذين أخبرونا نوعًا ما أنهم قالوا إنه
سيكون هناك ضرر، لكننا لسنا
متأكدين تمامًا من مدى حدوثه ولكن
لم يكن هناك على الرغم من البداية المؤلمة  لقد
اجتاز أوين جميع
مراحل النمو في مستشفى مينيسوتا للأطفال ولا
توجد علامات على تلف في الدماغ،
وتم إرساله إلى المنزل بعد 11 يومًا فقط من
ولادته. أخبرني السيد الذي تحدثت معه أنه
لم يستخدم كلمة معجزة من قبل طوال
حياته المهنية حتى  بعد رؤية هذا،
يعتقد فريق أوينز الطبي أن الكثير من
الفضل يعود إلى الأطباء والممرضات وإلى
ما يسمى وسيلة النقل المعزولة،
وهي ما تم استخدامه لنقل أوين من
مستشفى ميرسي إلى ولاية مينيسوتا للأطفال،
فنحن في الواقع
نبطئ أجسامهم لإتاحة الوقت
للتعافي والحفاظ على الجسم.  تقول الدكتورة هايدي
كامراث إن تبريد جسم أوين لمدة 72
ساعة سمح له بالتغلب على احتمالات
ولادة الأطفال لـ 3000 طفل سنويًا
لكنهم لن ينسوا أوين في أي وقت قريب
وفي أي وقت لديك قصة
تتجاوز توقعاتك نوعًا ما، وهذا
ما يجعلك تستمر في العمل  والقيام بهذه المهمة
هو الحصول على تلك النتائج الرائعة،
كل هذا ولد أوين في
الثامن من فبراير والذي صادف أنه
عيد ميلاد أخته هازل، لقد ساعدتني كثيرًا، فهي
تساعدني في إعطاء الزجاجات
وليس تغيير الحفاضات،
والحمد لله أنه لا يزال هناك وقت لذلك،
نعم  رائحتك كريهة